Today we're going
to talk about how
one goes beyond the basic
education and college degree
into the world of
lifelong learning.
In the past, with a good
education under your belt,
you could hope that
your employer would
take responsibility
for providing more
training and ongoing education.
But in today's world
of work, there's
less training that's
provided by employers.
So it's more important
for individuals
to think about what
they need to do
to take care of their
lifelong learning needs.
That means you have
to have a strategy.
So let's start with
those in high school.
In high school the
message that we emphasize
is that it's important to
stay in school, to work hard,
to graduate in good standing.
Nothing is more
important than that.
If you can while you
are in high school
get internships, co-op jobs,
part-time jobs in the summer
or even during the school
year if that's possible
so that you can begin to see
what the world of work is like.
Maybe you can meet some
people who are good role
models in the workplace.
Maybe you can test whether you
are really interested in one
kind of a job or another.
Maybe you can get
some technical skills
that will help you identify
what you really are good at.
Let me give you the
advice of Dr. James
Fico, an industrial
psychologist who
works with employers to match
good, talented young people
with the jobs that
are available.
Dr. Fico says, "There are plenty
of good jobs in my sectors--
manufacturing and
law enforcement.
Retirements are creating
lots of opportunities.
Employers expect much more
of their employees today
than at anytime in my memory.
They want technical skills, and
they want a much higher caliber
of job readiness and character.
Students' best bet
is to find mentors
for whom they can learn from
over a longer period of time."
And employers want a great
deal of the following.
They want courage.
They want integrity.
They want a devotion to
the job and a commitment
to really doing a great job.
They want a vision
for the future of what
the work might look like.
They want a commitment
to working in teams.
And, yes, of course, they
want technical competence.
The first four of these are
the most desired and maybe
the hardest to find, according
to Dr. Fico, regardless
of the age of the applicant.
But then he goes
on to say that "I
find that the most critical
language of the workplace today
is the language of math."
A thorough knowledge of
arithmetic, he says, yes,
he means basic math--
algebra, geometry,
basic adding and subtracting--
would do more for
business success
than any other single discipline
outside of the character
features mentioned earlier.
Remember that "the best
mathematicians in the United
States led us into this
recession a few years ago
because they didn't
understand the numbers
they were working with and
how to really calculate risk."
What about those of
you who are going
to go on for technical
degrees in community colleges
after high school?
Well, here the key, from all
kinds of research and evidence,
is that the most
important thing to do
is to look for programs that
are well-linked to the employers
in your region and in the
industry you want to work in.
Employers working with
community colleges
and vocational schools,
designing the curriculum
together, providing advice
and mentoring for students,
and then helping to make
sure that the skills that
are being taught are the modern
skills needed on the job.
The second feature
is to make sure
that these programs that
you choose mix classroom
experience in teaching with
on-the-job opportunities
to apply those skills and to see
the relevance of the material
that you are learning in
the classroom first hand.
The third feature of a
successful community college
and vocational
school is that they
have success in
placing graduates
not only in that first
job but with employers
who have career pathways,
that is job ladders that allow
people to continue to learn
and to advance over time
and maybe to come back for
refresher courses as needed.
How about college graduates
and college students?
Well, the thing to do here
is to make sure again,
like in high school, one gains
experience while in school,
looking for those summer
internships or co-op
placements in schools
that provide that,
so that you can really start to
build your professional network
while you're still in school.
And again, test
whether you are really
well-suited for
different kinds of jobs.
Then it's important to seek
out mentors on your first job.
The evidence is very clear that
having a supervisor or a mentor
from somewhere else in
the organization that
helps you learn the
ropes and can then
vouch for you for other
jobs as they come along
is really critical to
your future success
in that organization.
It's important that
you pursue outside
educational opportunities.
Take advantage of
all the universities,
like MIT and other great
schools, that are now providing
online learning opportunities
so that you can deepen
your knowledge and broaden
out your professional base
over time.
It's also important
that you maintain
your professional networks
and your contacts over time.
Make sure that you are
interacting with your peers.
Ask your employers to make sure
that you have opportunities
to go to professional meetings
and to stay current in what
is going on and
build those networks
so that you have others who are
sharing the same experiences,
and you are learning together.
And then finally, it's
always important to keep
that resume up to date.
Keep one foot in the
external labor market
because you never
know when you will
have to draw on it for looking
for your next opportunity.
So I believe we are in a world
where lifelong learning now
becomes critical to
long-term career success.
Start by picking an
occupation, a profession that
is of interest to you.
And then keep working on
your career over time,
testing yourself.
Am I staying current?
Can I find a job in
my profession outside
of my current employer?
And do I keep my network
strong and up to date
so that I can draw on the
assistance of other people as
needed?